will the real Joe Biden please stand up
the National Archives admitting that
they're sitting on a treasure Trove of
over 5 000 emails where Joe Biden used a
fake name they could show that the big
guy was actively involved in Hunter's
Shady business dealings
known aliases for Biden include Robin
Ware Robert L Peters and jrb Ware I
guess McLovin was already taken
so it's
just McLovin
yeah
a badass it is badass really cool yeah a
lot of people weird names nowadays you
think that's bad Hunter Biden's grift
seems to be going strong the White House
is refusing to rule out that the first
sun is still cashing in on his dad's
name
we know that from 100 Biden associate
now that he sold the appearance of
access to
then vice president died
are you confident that he has stopped
doing that that is a question from
Hunter Biden if somebody is selling the
appearance of accidents that is a
question for the White House no that is
that is your um your I don't know how
you're perceiving that
testimony Archer I am just not
Peter I'm just not going to get into
this I'm just not I'm a little bored the
evidence against Biden's piling up the
Democrats are finding new ways to
embarrass themselves while defending the
first family watch
one day he's sleepy Joe the next day
he's corrupt Joe I know people who are
sleepy I know people who are corrupt I
don't know anyone who is both these guys
just know that they are reflexively
anti-anything Biden's doing are you
confident when you look at what the
justice department has done when you
look at the investigations into Hunter
Biden that the Republicans have pursued
up to this point that there hasn't been
any wrongdoing everything's been above
board yes I'm extremely uh confident the
American people know fundamentally that
Joe Biden is a good and decent man all
right Jenna you were in the federal
government how often do people use Alias
emails to correspond I would love for
the reporters who were in The Briefing
room when I was press secretary to
revisit
the stories that they did when there was
this minor issue about people who are
trying to do the right thing to make
sure when they were dealing with the RNC
if they had a political job at the White
House dealing with the RNC that they
used the right email it became this
gigantic Scandal we answered all the
questions there was Congressional
testimony you had to turn over all the
documents the RNC to this day still has
all of them archived and it turned out
it was absolutely nothing I would love
to see the Curiosity from the media on
this one I don't think that they're
going to get it and when Eric swalwell
is your first line of defense for
dealing with a foreign influence and
fraternizing campaign you are not in a
good place you are really not in a good
place and then he said I I can't imagine
he could be both sleepy and corrupt at
the same time and actually this might be
something that Biden can do like this is
like this could actually happen
um the other thing is Jesse I was
thinking about you earlier because
you've utilized the foia Freedom of
Information Act request in order to get
information for stories that you're
pursuing and it's available to the
American public it's also available
multimedia organizations and sometimes
they use it but in these particular
stories where has all the news nuggets
come from it's not from the media filing
a foia request asking to find out if Joe
Biden had aliases it's coming from
private organizations sometimes our
partisan organizations that's also fine
it's under the First Amendment but the
media is so incurious it really bothers
me so what do you think he was hiding
with 5400 emails over eight years you
know I come from a different place than
Dana but for me you know it's basically
the same it's a clear attempt to avoid
any kind of transparency sharing
information allegedly about his schedule
that includes issues of the Ukraine at
the time when Joe Biden was a point man
on energy in Ukraine and according to
the National Archives 5400 such emails
5400 such emails I'll say it again and
it was during the years it was Joe Biden
was vice president 14 and 15. at that
that was those were the years that David
Weiss the now special counsel uh allowed
the statute of limitations to run uh the
the years that under the
1023 the bidens were pretty much
demanding 5 million and 5 million
dollars from zlav chesky who was the
head of barisma
um and and by the way who was copied on
the email the staff member is told to
send it to uh Hunter Biden and that
shows that uh the immediate staff around
Joe Biden knew that Hunter Biden was
involved in this we already know that
Obama's people and Obama State
Department said you got to watch out for
your son we all know he's a dirtbag drug
addicts x-rays lunatic and he's flying
around with you and you know uh the the
the this has to stop but you know it it
this is really in the end it's a story
of a father's deep love for his son and
um I mean who Among Us hasn't done 5400
emails using a different name for any
reason I know what your secret name is I
don't want to ask don't say it so judge
makes an interesting point if now
staffers were being copied on these
emails this is an Administration wide
scandal
would you expect house oversight to
maybe subpoena some of these people yeah
again uh they're next uh so they're
gonna I imagine do that and it was a
Southeastern Legal Foundation that asked
for it a year ago so in June of 2022
they say you got these uh three aliases
can you tell us what emails went out
during the Obama years and they said
okay I'll get back to you I don't know a
year so we get back when it turns out
that 5400 we'll get back to you we'll
get them to you eventually we do know
this that 10 of those emails were copied
to Hunter between May 18th and June 15th
uh and so we also understand too that
the There Was an explanation when Obama
had an alias they said well we have to
throw off the Chinese or would be
hackers by using a different email and
I'm thinking to myself if we can't
protect the president United States
email we're all doomeds no wonder North
Korea was able to bring these movie
studios down to their knees and can I
just say also a big surprise you went to
meet Beaufort Pierce because you like
him better and from me I thought for
sure you'd go to pierce you eat up all
the time
look I realized that the occupant of
this particular chair on this show has
to try and master some form of defending
the indefensible when it comes to
President Biden and this Scandal I have
nothing uh because this stinks the whole
thing just stinks
and I think with any political Scandal
you go back right to the start what's
the Nugget what's the fact that what's
the Catalyst for all of this and the
Catalyst for this is the underbined with
zero experience possibly less lands a
job on the board of a major Ukrainian
Energy company and he gets paid 83
333 dollars a month to offer his zero
expertise to this Ukrainian Energy
company do
father is Vice President of the United
States with special responsibility for
Ukraine
if you just take that one fact at the
start of this Scandal that is corruption
so everything that follows is
unsurprising to me because you know
there's a scandal you know it's
corruption you know that Hunter Biden
got that job because of his dad you know
they're making loads of money as a
family the Biden brand was fleecing
Ukraine for gazelle we can add something
to this it's not hypothetical we know
exactly it seems in 2014 Hunter enlisted
according to the Daily Mail and emails
that have been acquired boys Schiller
flexner uh group this Law Firm to go
ahead and advise them how to stop the
investigation into the CEO of barisma of
course and then choking this guy gets
fired shokin takes over he continues and
they say how do we stop choking so
that's why Hunter was fun was hired and
he actually did something for the job
with all these things if you just
substitute Biden for Trump and this was
Donald Trump Jr with Donald Trump as the
it's the same story by the way I'm not
but if you if you if you just subbed the
names round what would all the people
trying to defend Biden be saying about
the trumps absolutely if they had done
this they would have been screaming for
impeachment for indictments and
everything else instead there's a
deafening silence and that is frankly
with the mainstream media in this
country I have to say that as a
journalist that is as corrupt as the
actual Scandal itself that they're not
treating this the way they would if it
was someone on the other side but it's
the same story that got them impeached
they were Rudy Giuliani was pursuing
this story and he shouldn't have and
they shouldn't have done it this way
against a point we know that but this is
the same story they go what was Biden do
in Ukraine but Trump was calling up so
once he'd go could you find out because
I'm going to send my guy over and that's
the story and now two years later we're
pursuing a story and they're definitely
trying to slow it down and you know one
of the interesting things is that when
you say that they hired the law firm of
David Boyce and then choking comes in
and they figure out they can't they
can't figure out a way to get rid of him
so Joe Biden says I'll get rid of him
myself I'll Leverage
yeah and I'll admit it to him television
it's a scandal folks
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else